Speaker 1: One of the popular talking points
that's developed among the right wing media,
including Fox News, recently, is that Joe Biden
is making gas prices higher by not restarting
construction of the Keystone XL pipeline and built
into this entire story, our misunderstandings
about what the Keystone XL pipeline is and what it
would do, how long it would take to construct it,
as well as the degree to which president's impact
gas prices, particularly when the price of oil
is soaring globally. And all of these things are
being missed with really kind of it's not even
really pedantic. They're just confused the talking
points from right wingers. One example that we're
going to look at right now is Peter Doocy from
Fox News. For days, Doocy has been hammering
Joe Biden's White House press secretary Jen Psaki
about gas prices and the Keystone XL pipeline,
and he seems to understand very
little about it. Not surprisingly, so
let's look at his first attempt from yesterday
or his latest attempt. I guess we would call it
from a press briefing yesterday on this talking
point. And then I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the truth about Keystone XL,
Speaker 2: because there's a lot of gray
area. Here is a restart of the Keystone XL
construction completely off the table as
long as Joe Biden is president?
Speaker 3: Well, why don't you
tell me what would that would help address?
Speaker 2: I'm asking you if it is an option.
You guys say all options are on the table. Is
restarting keystone construction one of them?
Speaker 3: If we're trying to bring about more
supply that does not address any problem in
Speaker 2: supply from Canada, a friendly ally.
Speaker 3: And so that's already that's what we're
already getting that oil. Peter, it's the
pipeline is just a delivery mechanism and is
not an oilfield, so it does not provide more
supply into the system. It does not address.
Speaker 2: Is it possible that Joe
Biden will ever say this can go
ahead with construction of Keystone XL?
Speaker 3: There's no plans for that,
and it would not address any of the
problems we're having currently.
Speaker 1: OK, so all of these right wingers
talking about Keystone XL, Keystone XL.
First of all, as Jen Psaki points out, it's
merely a pipeline. It's not a source of oil,
and Canadian oil is already coming into the
United States, the pipeline in Canada. And
here's the most important thing. Now, yesterday on
my stream, I asked people in my in the audience,
Do you guys realize that phases one, two
and three of the Keystone XL pipeline
are already up and running? When they talk
about Keystone XL and when they talk about,
Oh, Biden stopped it and Trump tried to do it and
Obama stopped it. Do you guys realize that it's
just phase four of Keystone XL? 95 percent of my
audience didn't know that. And that's by design
when the right says they've stopped Keystone XL.
We're getting no oil phases. One, two and three
of the Keystone XL pipeline are and have been
up and running. It runs, I believe, from Canada,
from Alberta to Illinois and Texas and Oklahoma.
These pipelines are already in place. What's at
issue when people say Biden stopped? It is Biden
stopped construction of phase four, and there's
controversy around phase four because of how
it would go through indigenous land and the the
indigenous communities that would be affected have
not really been players at the table in a way that
many of us in the United States think they should
be. So Obama delayed it, and then Trump tried to
resume that construction and then Biden stopped
it and ultimately took the energy. The company
in place has abandoned it. So first and foremost.
Keystone XL is up and running. Phase one is up and
running. Phase two is up and running. Phase three
is up and running. Number two, it is not a method
of supply. It is a method of transport. And number
three, it would take probably years to complete if
you started that construction right now, and it
would be a very modest amount of oil relative to
the total U.S. need. It's a silly bogus talking
point, even if Biden said, let's do phase four.
It would not solve the problem right now in any
way. Do see continuing to just use these confused,
different talking points here, trying
to do a gotcha around calling the gas
price increases the Putin price hikes.
Speaker 2: Hey, did you guys decide to
rebrand the rise in gas prices
as the hashtag Putin price hike?
Speaker 3: I mean, if you want to
use that on Fox, I welcome that.
Speaker 2: But I think it will get a lot of
airtime because we have heard the president
warn for months the gas prices were rising
because of the supply chain and because of
post-pandemic demand. If you guys knew for months
that this was going to be the hashtag coupon
price hike, why don't we just hearing that now?
Speaker 1: Well, so of course, I mean, Jen Psaki's
answer doesn't even matter again. Gas prices can
go up at different times for different reasons,
and the when remember when gas prices started
going up at the end of Trump's presidency
and they continued going up when Joe Biden took
over? It was a global phenomenon as a result of
the resumption in demand with the easing of the
pandemic. We now are seeing gas prices go up more.
And it has to do with expectations. Remember,
oil prices are sort of a futures market.
We are now seeing it happen as a result of
what's going on in Russia, Ukraine and for
supply reasons, et cetera. All of these things can
be true. It's sort of like if I wake up one day
and I have a headache because I didn't sleep
well, and then that night I bumped my head,
and the next day I have an even worse
headache. It'd be like, Well, why did you?
Why did you say it was because you were tired on
day one? Because you actually bumped your head
right on day one? The headache was because I was
tired on day two. It was because I bumped my head.
Different causes can have a similar effect.
One more example of the confusion around this
Keystone XL thing here is former Obama economic
adviser Robert Wolff on Fox News, and he says
this Keystone XL thing would not actually fix the
problem we're dealing with right now. And the Fox
anchor says, Well, that's debatable. No, it's not.
Speaker 3: All right. So if that's not going
to happen, Robert, perhaps as Peter just
reported, perhaps opening up the Keystone
Pipeline is not off the table for this White
House. What did you take away from that?
Speaker 4: I think Xcel is off the
table. Let's recall a few things. One,
it's the worst type of oil. You can have its tar
sands going from Alberta to the Gulf of Mexico. It
wasn't going to really change anything to do with
our oil supply. It was to export from the Gulf of
Mexico. Also that the three in Trump? Well, let me
just fit. OK, it's not actually debatable. It has
nothing to do with oil fields. It's a pipeline
and it was going to end of the Gulf of Mexico.
That's a fact. You should look it up. Yeah.
Speaker 1: This is the problem. You know how
I've been saying to you guys one of the problems
we have right now in America and sort of in the
media milieu and in society in general is people
don't agree about what our facts now. The wording
I'm using is very important. I'm not saying
people don't agree about what the facts are.
That would be like, I think, you know, I wrote
down, what about the fact I think inflation's
gone up and you think it's gone down, OK, whatever
like that would be a disagreement about the facts.
People don't agree about what types of statements
or statements of fact. The Keystone XL pipeline
is something in particular. It's not open to
opinion. What the Keystone XL pipeline is or where
it would have been, or how much oil it would have
transported, or whether it's a source of oil or
just a transport method. Those are not opinions.
Those are things we can definitively know.
And the problem is when the Fox News anchor says,
Well, that's debatable. It's really not. I mean,
you can make an argument that it's something
else you would be wrong. It's not a statement
of opinion. These are statements of fact. And just
look at previous reporting about the pipeline from
when Obama was president. And there are actually
reports from back then that say, phase four of
Keystone XL could actually cause a gas price
increase in the Midwest, in particular because
the oil would be transported through there.
But it's not intended for American consumers.
The reporting is out there, so they don't know
as usual what the hell they're talking about.